hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to inscription we're
about to find out what this new area is
oh wow
well isn't this lovely you're not used
to seeing five lanes aren't you
unless you could never pull that off i'm
exactly one better than him
man you're just a prick i should have
chosen to replace you but i don't think
it would have changed the outcome at all
all right uh
what is that over there what do you have
there
49er okay i know what that does
uh oh it's my energy bar i see
empty vessel
okay energy bot
you don't have the energy battery bearer
when a card bearing the sigil is played
it provides an energy sell to its owner
well that's handy
sniper bot
choose which opposing space oh
that's nice okay good but i don't have
anything so i might as well just block
what that does it'll only do it for one
turn but whatever go
oh
okay whoa oh
empty vessels i only have one other
thing in my deck at all i think i don't
know what it is but
uh
it's gonna help me get another energy
but it's gonna cost my energy
anyway let me just draw whatever my
shield bot okay
first time a card bearing the sigil
would take damage to prevent that damage
okay
i'll play that once that thing comes out
i'll put energy bot here he's gonna die
but he'll take the hit for me okay cool
that's fine ow
so i'll put shield bot down there to
kill that thing i only have empty
vessels
i better be careful
well if i put empty vessel down i could
kill that thing
which might be nice
yeah kill one or kill the other it's all
the same
let's try this
all right and then might as well do the
empty vessel where this automaton is
gonna go okay
wham
oh
it didn't explode i thought it was gonna
explode
oh it doesn't do that anymore oh you're
just gonna change the rules on me oh
thanks thanks preach that that's very
helpful
whatever all right uh
sniper bot
let's see what i can do and shoot
[Music]
bro
they're all the same pretty much bam
okay shift and balance back a bit
okay double gunner finally
okay you're gonna attack yeah okay
perfect so you attack there
and
that's it
you hit
that one because everything's going to
be taken care of there we go
easy peasy
[Music]
all right what does it matter wham
can i shoot
well
[Music]
there we go
take that buddy boo oh you're not dead
yet okay well
sure
wham wham wham take some overkill my
friend take some fat overkill thank you
thank you for that
priest big preach the best defense other
bots
you carry a spark that can uh reactivate
old bots
add them to your deck you know
and they fight for you you're not a very
good storyteller
all right what do we have here
energy bots swap bot
after a card bearing the sigil is dealt
damage spot its power and health oh
that's cool
i mean that's pretty dope honestly
honestly i like that that's super cool
but if he never gets i could use my
sniper bot maybe to hit him
that might be nice
hello
hello okay
hey can i get from my table i guess not
whatever it's fine
okay
you'll need more than a few reactivated
bots that is if you truly wish to enact
to the great transcendence but do i do i
wish to enact that autopia has some of
the most op items just lying around
do they
oh that will recharge your energy one
turn
pretty good
all right if you're smart you'll use
your items liberally you'll replenish
them at waypoints obviously
maybe not obviously you know i don't
really know how this game works it's a
new game
how do i know what's going on whoa
shield bond broken bot but broken bot
explodes
my card bringing this sigil dies the
creature opposing it i thought so the
bomb bot didn't do that though that's
interesting okay empty vessel it is oh i
can still break things cool
oh
i know what card that is i don't need it
yet i guess i could use another empty
vessel
oh wait no i had the shield bot down
there of course it didn't take any
damage i'm dumb i can
put down my energy bot
right here
there
refill my energy like it's telling me i
can
well i'll just put this empty vessel
down
there
then refill like it's saying me should
do so
then
good there
take this shoot that one
now shield is gone which is fine
oh
cool
now i know what this is but still i only
have four energy
yeah okay let me just draw oh there's
two cards actually all right right right
the double gunner i forgot about that
one so oh i should have
interesting i should have moved that
somewhere else because then i could have
shot that and killed both of those but
it's okay
yeah
you're gonna shoot i guess you could
shoot this thing but i think it might
kill you anyway
all right whatever
a little bit of a goodbye
whoa
thanks
ow
all right i'm now at six energy correct
no not yet well that's unfortunate
how the vessel it is
cool
[Laughter]
well looks like it's a game over for you
my friend there's no way to get more
overkill damage is there there probably
is it's a little overkill it's fine
okay kabam you lose thank you just one
overkill but it would ever
all right what do we have here
insecto drone double gunner leap bot
basically just an empty vessel that can
block against flight which isn't that
useful i'd rather have another double
gunner
do some damage
okay the real best way to fight back
against those rogue bots modify yours
give them op abilities
okay choose a card from your deck uh
swap bot
let's see
well that's not helpful
what about this one energy bot
all right that's all you have to offer
just that and guard dog ooh this might
be good on swa the thorns might be going
on swap up because then if it gets hit
by a one thing it can kill it
immediately then strike
so it doesn't have to waste another turn
that might be good
let's go with that
oh yeah
very satisfied
let's go
hmm
you're almost at the waypoint don't
choke now
i mean i'll try not to
we'll see what happens
oh wow bridge
what do you have there alarm bot
creature opposing his card bearing the
sizzle gains one power
[Music]
okay well that's helpful i think
i mean okay well this empty vessel will
then be able to
get it but i won't kill it right away
it's gonna kill that
okay whatever
oh
so now it can kill it which is nice and
i can't play anything else but that's
fine
[Music]
oh so it does do damage if it goes
forward okay that's cool
[Music]
well i need that empty vessel to die
anyway to replace it so might as well
take this shot
oh swap bot incoming
[Music]
i think this is going to win me it
because i will snipe that thing out of
the
out of existence and then
i win
right
take this shot wham boom boom
done
ah not enough overkill i know i can do
better than that
that's fine it's fine
ah you made it to the waypoint cool
oh
your items are recharged bots that
you've destroyed in the area will stay
that way if and when you do perish
you'll be brought back here it's an
elegant system sure it is
oh
money
i like money whoa
central blautopia oh this is funky
okay cool
shop
glorious commerce your robo bucks are
accepted here
i can't really afford much of this
another card would be nice though i'll
take that
okay energybot explodebod sniperbot
i mean energy buffs pretty cool you know
like energy bought
i like energy bot energy blots good i
like having energy but i'm gonna try to
make sure i actually do overkill things
pretty hard
eastern bottopia not much of value out
this way well i'm going anyway because
shut up but you've still got to explore
here you know for the great
transcendence
sure
sure thing
this is fun i like being back into this
kind of world it makes it uh
makes it nice
okay
empty vessel easy
[Music]
part
another empty vessel
oh god i should have done energy bot
first god i'm stupid i'm really dumb
guys guys i'm really dumb
[Music]
energy bot
first
then put the empty vessel down
i could have put sniper bot down i'm an
idiot
[Music]
empty vessel time
it's fine guys it's fine don't worry
about it it's fine don't worry about it
chabusky
oh why did i put him there
i don't know
oh boy
a double gun
one
two got wait no i do not want to
overkill him just yet
i really don't i know this seems strange
but i don't want to kill him yet because
i'm trying to get those sweet overkill
bucks
oh
just got to be careful so i'll put this
guy down here because he's he'll swap
and then i'll do the double gunner
right
ha
oh he didn't swap god damn it
what else do i have here shield bot
uh
okay
okay he's two hits away from death i'm
gonna just do this
one damage okay cool is this my other
dog yes it's my other double gunner so
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna destroy
this thing
i'm gonna play the double gunner i'm
gonna recharge my power play the other
double gunner and this should be way
overkill bang boom bang boom bang boom
i wish i'd played this differently oh
hell yeah hell yeah thank you for the
money
appreciate it appreci are you wondering
about that star i am now you've been
winning a lot now you got a bounty on
your head it's sure to attract bounty
hunters it resets when you die though
well all right bring them on
i'm fine with that
old town shield bot
sentry drone uh i could do a level one
thing it would be nice i do like a
shield bot though but the boldhound
could be good
steelbot's very useful i think
shielbot's the way to go all right but
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna go back
to the store and spin this moolah i've
got oh
let me guess what you're thinking go
back to the waypoint refresher items
made a go of the shop i actually want
you to win but it can't be that easy you
can go back to the waypoint but all the
rogue bots you've cleared in this area
will respawn so you sure
yeah i'll fight him again what do you
mean of course i will hell yeah i don't
know what that is but
i get it eventually
okay i don't want to get the mistake of
getting too many cards
another swampbot 49er i think this
swapbot has potential i like the idea of
the swapbot
but the bolthound is good bolt hound
let's do both hounds just to keep it
varied
all right
let's go fight again because that's
great
[Music]
get more mule off for doing an overkill
what you got over there
oh
whoa zip one ball
name simphon boom i'll be taking that
scalp at yours nothing personal kid
uh-huh sure you will okay yeah let's see
how that goes for you uh to be
perfectly fair it won't go well in case
you were curious let me go ahead and put
down well let me pick up another thing
oh yeah sniper bots could but let me go
ahead and do this four damage
here
yep
okay one more damage and we're good okay
he took some back but that's fine
because we're about to go ham
on him
by doing a funky little maneuver
yep we're gonna do a funky little
maneuver
easy enough
give me that overkill bang boom bang
boom
ah sweet delicious overkill
thank you
thank you kindly i wonder if i'd have
killed that bounty hunter if it would
have been more let me see what's up this
way oh hi money thank you money
what is that about it's probably
something important
oh
all right let's see what we can do
automaton broken bolt
well standard is a standard does
hey welcome to the party everybody all
right what do we need what do we need
we're about to get swanked
we need to start putting out some other
cards shieldbot is helpful
ah i know what i'm gonna do okay that's
easy enough
this is how we're going to kill this
thing
we're going to put that there and that's
going to take the hit
this is going to do one two three i can
survive it
let's go swap
it'll take the hit and that's fine
okay i gotta do some damage and then
it's gonna hit back next time
[Music]
how many hits away am i two hits okay
cool
here's what i'm gonna do
sniper bot's gonna take one for the team
because he's a team player like that
yeah this is gonna snipers gonna go over
there empty vessel right there
sniper bot is going to hit the bomb here
wham
boom boom bam
then that dies that dies no damage which
is good
double gunner's gonna help me get back
onto the field
by doing some damage one it'll do two
damage i'm only gonna take one this time
good
wham wham wham okay we're back on the
field ow
i just gotta be careful about that one
i'm thinking empty vessel might be the
way to go just because of
it's
it's going to die to that anyway i'm
going to do two more damage take one
damn yeah we're good
there we go
oh
that's fine
love that
let me see okay one two three four five
six
seven hits away
this is gonna work out quite nicely
oh but i don't wanna kill it yet i want
that overkill sorry shieldbot you gotta
go i wanna do six damage not seven
thank you
for your sacrifice
you'll be remembered
[Music]
just to barely
oh yeah boldhound
bolt hound yes please
all right full damage
love it bang a boom bolt down's got a
gun everybody watch out bolt hounds got
a freaking gun
yeah
oh yeah that's what i'm talking about
all right so what was up this other way
it was up this weird thing this
crackling there but it seems like it
needs like i need to connect power to it
or something
probably whoa
okay
huh
interesting it's like a hidden choice it
wasn't there before it's only there when
you point at it so that must be teaching
me that there are places that i can go
that it's not showing me
sometimes funky
oh thank you
thank you for the cards amiibot
when a card bearing the schedule the
sigil is replaced with another sigil at
random well that could be nice i'll give
it a go why not could be fun
could be dope maybe i'll get a rabbit
hello
amiibot oh
what is that one
ah you can never die that's very helpful
all right cool i'll take that
why are you electrified why are you
electrified i don't like that
moderately concerning
[Applause]
all right what do i have i have energy
bot and then a me bot i want to do both
but i can't do both i need this and an
empty vessel
okay energy bot first
you're gonna get some power because that
one's annoying
and maybe i should do this
because this can still kill this oh you
can't kill the oh right you explode i
did that wrong but it's fine
[Music]
for some reason i thought this had one
you have 11 health oh honey don't cry
i'm rust hobenstein i'll make it swift
you have 11 health
good god well i'm going to kill you all
right amiibot is good for this one
that's good
um i'm just going to get this in my hand
because
okay amiibot can take care of this thing
that's good amiibot go
i don't need to play that yet
haha as if oh it changes every time
interesting oh you broke the rails oh
interesting very interesting what else
we got shield bot
i like that
what's this one
loses one power ah
well doesn't matter let's just go ahead
and
yeah shieldbot there and amiibot just
because
double gunner love that love that for me
okay you're gonna chip away at this guy
and the rails apparently
oh
all right swap bot will be good for this
but after he gets hit again he's not
going to do so good
wham wham wham wham four
hey nothing
oh cause amibot lowered its attack to
zero when it swapped it at zero health
that's cool
i like that a lot okay but double
gunner's gonna die here as soon as that
goes over there but swapbot's gonna kill
this thing
go
ouch it's all right darling remember the
name russ hoppenstein i'll be back
will you i think you're dead
how will you be back
ow
all right i don't think i'm gonna get
much overkill here but i am gonna win
three four it's a little overkill
yeah it's nice i don't think there's
anything else to do
well i guess i could sniper body get him
one more why not right
bam
three's not bad i'll take three
thanks
i like this game another star in your
head your bounty is higher bounty
hunters of a higher caliber may become
calling
okay but there's no there's no real
reward in
fighting a miser items are 100 charge
bot spawners 100 offline
oh
blame
power's dead on this old thing
i'll let you get up if you go get a new
battery
uh
okay thank
you you're allowed in the inspection
room only
just give me the battery from the
inspectometer and come back what can you
not move or something
what is that
whoa
oh
hello okay
print progress looks like a hundred
percent
okay
huh
hi how you doing how you doing pal
okay
oh weird oh more puzzles
this is gonna kill that thing
there we go
oh hi
mrs bomb's remote sure take it drop
bombs on every empty space tactical
board wipe don't be stupid about it okay
thanks
thank you okay what is that
the magic is still here there's still
magic
really okay well that's not gonna do
anything to that
one to one kill so that does nothing
three to two kills that but doesn't it
let me go look at if there must be like
a book
yeah here we go gem detonator when gem
vessels on the underside of the board
die they detonate
the creature opposing them as well oh
okay okay interesting that's what that
does this explodes and damages all that
so this kills that when it dies which is
no good
for anybody this kills our things so we
don't need that but that's going to kill
that it's like a chain reaction right
and without this first thing dying
nothing chains
this is this wait is that jim
just a plus
oh when gem vessels
oh it doesn't blow up when gem vessels
blow up that's what i wasn't getting
wrong so because this is there that gem
vessel will blow up when it dies
which it needs to
to blow up this this is what we're
looking for
right
all that matters is getting this thing
out of the game so if we can kill that
thing then that'll cause that to blow up
which will kill that that and that so we
need to blow that up so we need to that
there
okay that took me way
too long
okay
sorry
i didn't understand the cars for a while
lonely wizbot ah is it
is this
stimulation
something other than darkness
many thanks
do with me what you will
anything but that uh infinite darkness
okay i will do with you what i will
thank you for the help
all right anyway i'm gonna go in here oh
i left those things turned on
that's fine just solve some easy puzzles
all right i did definitely
rotate until sigil is turned upright
well these are pretty easy
i feel like this is what it should be
okay yay i did it
okay good
hi
it's select all the squares that contain
cards
it's like
what is that
[Music]
oh
really
ah i see i see i see
contain cards okay
cool i don't like what i'm seeing over
there
great hi
hello
hi oh hi
who are you
this is fine i saw
oh
okay
i don't know what i'm doing are you one
of his assistants that uh he
well you left
into the manufacturing process okay
i think that's the battery but
what is this
oh fish bot
found me good robot fish hide me revenge
for last time
bad fish okay good
hi
i'll take that thank you
yeah that's fine
okay got it
yep that's it bring it over
okay is there something else i could do
with it
probably not
hi
i'm back now
there you go yep thanks
okay
oh that should do it back to the game
yeah back to the game oh what is that
well i could go back to the shop i think
i have enough money to find out what the
hell that bunny was
oh nope sorry
what is 18 ah not enough all right i'll
come back later for it
let's keep going the way i'm going just
because i feel like it
[Music]
revolting yeah sorry that you have to
see this it's the last area in bautopia
that still has life in it that stinking
squirming massive imperfection um well i
can't am partial to that stinking
swirling mass of imperfection kind of
like it you know
if there's other paths that i can go oh
hello
grizz
whoa what's grizz at the beginning of
your turn a card bearing this sigil
will transform to or from beast mode
sonia
at the beginning okay
weird what does beast mode do
i like grizz grizz is cool
i like grizz
grizz is cool and let me do some
exploring before i go i actually i think
that was the only thing i could do
all right
let's fight them
trees huh weird stimulation
lefty fish is near must find other
scribe fish too
deep beneath
uh-huh
yeah the robo seems to have taken over i
was supposed to take over but you know
whatever it's fine what are you gonna do
quiz quill
quill quiz quill quill quiz
sure
righty ho
a random card is created in your hand
wow okay i'll take that
old hound how did you get that out so
soon whoa what did you do quill ah
interesting
[Music]
okay interesting
all right well i just need to empty
vessel
because i don't have my energy bot
lonely wizard though what does that do
when one of your creatures is placed
into space a card-bearing decision will
move towards them as far as possible
klinger all right cool
okey dokey then um i could play that but
i'd take two damage anyway so what good
would it do
i mean it's gonna die anyway so whatever
i'll take the damage yes yes well you're
not gonna like this pal
all right so i'm faced with a bit of a
conundrum i don't exactly have a lot of
stuff that i could do if i had a bomb
bot or something i might be able to
handle something but i do not
uh if i play him i can't play any other
and i'm about to take some big damage i
could bomb the place uh
risk it for the biscuit ah damn it
all right well that wasn't what i wanted
let's blow the place up
oh
all right
you're not gonna kill explodebot here oh
there you go
well done pal
well done so what do i have
i have nothing you're gonna fly right
over anything i put in front of you so
it doesn't matter what i put in front of
you i have four energy
could put down a fishbot and an empty
vessel
let's draw a card sniper bot interesting
okay i can kill that thing definitely
that's probably the best way to go so
i'll just put the empty vessel down and
then sniper bot behind the cover of this
tree
wham and shoot
not having my energy by kind of sucks
but whatever
all right
damn it i can't afford to put you down
all right fish pie you're up
i'm bait
yeah you are
don't you
oh parishes okay whatever well you got
to be bait cause was that a fish gun
is that a fish gun are you gonna take
damage from this
[Music]
i want you to be alive
i can't risk it
oh bad
yeah a little bad but it's okay don't
worry about it it's fine now i'm gonna
draw a good card
bolt hound huh
interesting
okay
[Music]
don't even think about it pal
swampbot
merely mediocre all right fish boy you
gotta go
bam thank you bad fish
oh
after attacking a card bearing the sigil
perishes ah how much damage it do i
can't even see because my fingers in the
way how much uh
i need to do some dabblage
[Music]
please don't be overkill
okay perfect perfect we're good we're
good we're good
what do we got
energy bot well that's not helpful
um
[Music]
sorry snipey butt you gotta go
you uh gots to go you served your
purpose well
need my overkill damage
bang a boom bang boom
that's what we're talking about
thank you merciless but fair
yeah well you feel bad about losing ah
you should
thank you for the moolah is there
another shop up here do i gotta go all
the way back oh
hi
there's gold
i was just about to mine it it's all i
need to work kick in the pants
okay thanks what is this
one of your cards is about to gain an
alter ego as a beast
and you get to choose which card and
which beast it's not that complicated
simulate me i'm guessing which beast
you're gonna be all right what about the
lonely whiz bot what do you get to be
let me calibrate ah
which beast okay which piece is that oh
i see it already tells me okay
no no no no no no i'll put the lowly no
no no put it in there put it in there
all right wolf does three in one
flying two in one snake but completely
lethal
i mean he's already crazy so it makes
sense that he would be a werewolf
yeah that makes sense i'm fine with this
thank you for the upgrade
good oh yeah so good
i love this game
okay what did you do you mined the sound
did you take all the gold what is that
oh
[Laughter]
oh no you came at a just the wrong time
the generator is about to explode or
something you have to recharge it before
that happens
it's a race against the clock you see
okay why
out of the deck into the hand okay but
uh how do i recharge it
okay well that doesn't do any damage so
what i have to do is i have to do enough
damage to get this charged is that what
i'm doing
i think that's what i'm doing okay so
i'm just gonna skip this turn it's fine
no it's fine don't worry about it it's
fine
when my face says zero you lose okay
cool that's great
not a big deal it's all good
shield bot not what i needed but this
guy can start
oh yes yeah you got it buddy
bang
oh
i really need to oh yeah that a boy
atta boy where's my energy bot amiibot
i really want my double gunner right
there because he would do a just a butt
load of damage
yeah me but
go
wham that's four that's pretty good okay
i probably get it just with this you're
running out of time no i'm not i'm fine
don't worry about it don't worry about
me i'm good
grizz and i can't even play so many six
energy cards i can't do anything
yeah shield bottle help
oh no
you clingy god damn you oh god
damn you well that's annoying
should have put an empty vessel in
between them i guess
uh well there goes that
oops it's fine it's fine it's fine
can i please there we go energy bot well
it's not going to help me
okay it's fine
because i'll plop it down anyway if i
was desperate i would do it but i don't
need it i think i think actually i got
it on this turn too
if i don't i'll definitely on the next
one come on
you recharged it before it exploded if i
could clap for you i would
okay cool i did it
what were the stakes and uh what do i
get money and uh upgrade that's pretty
cool
pick one of your cards
oh i don't know uh lonely wizbot you
just get so much i'm just gonna load
this guy up because he needs the
stimulation what do we have all right
flying defend nah
shield uh that's pretty good sentry oh
i'm gonna give him the the super shield
all right you get a shield he is just so
stimulated the memory unit on this one
won't be able to take much more oh i
don't know about that it can take the
stimulation if there's one thing i know
about it it's that the stimulation will
never be enough
definitely needs a little more if you
ask me
hey what a way out there what we have
here
perfect good job of me bot
love that and love you oh how do you get
these things out so soon
it doesn't seem very fair
oh boy that's a bear that's what you
might call the bear
no that's not gonna do anything i can't
it's gonna go right over it
it's gonna turn oh that's sonja
transformed okay i see well amiibot can
start chipping away at it oh or i could
put a meebo here
that'll help there i know i didn't get
the energy vessel out but for now at
least i can start putting money on
damage on the board
and it can do that oh hi
blast van rust reporting for duty my
mission eliminate target flicked bounty
after that maybe start a small business
a betting breakfast something nice
settle down find a partner manufacture
some children
grow old pass a business onto my
children rest away content with my life
work surrounded by my family
yeah but first eliminate target
i love that guy man i'm gonna hate to
kill him
ow
yeah grizz you go away you're mean
i gotta grizz of my own but i don't
think he's gonna do me very good um okay
energy bot
you do thorns damage you move and push
yeah mebot's gonna kill that thankfully
i'm gonna put down my energy bot
go ahead and oh oops you're right thank
you
here empty vessel
here
okay that'll do
bang boom thank you
did it deserve that
i don't think it did
okay we got five energy that's good
poor amiibot is gonna bite the dust but
i actually might have enough damage ah
no just one away let's see what we can
get
two shield bots i like that you go there
cause he's about to move yeah you go
there
i wish i could kill that guy i don't
think i'm gonna be able to before i
win because i'm amazing
okay that was three damage ooh right on
the precipice
ow
okay well now i have nothing so that's a
little bit of a problem
uh i don't know if he's gonna move over
before that thing comes down which would
save my ass but
i now have six okay double gunner
that is nice that is nice i don't think
i'm gonna be able to kill him
i mean maybe i could
maybe it might be worth trying to kill
him i'm kind of curious three total
damage
okay this might be worth it
literally i think it might be worth it
that's gonna transform
transform and then attack me i don't
know
what what why oh the thorns right the
thorns oh god wait no stop stop stop oh
that's not good
maybe i got a little over-ambitious oh
my god okay it's fine
totally fine
totally fine what's in my deck i don't
know but this is totally fine what do i
got
ah fishbot thank you that's helpful
you're gonna die very intensely okay
so i think this is gonna go
i'll play grizz here because what i
think is gonna happen he's gonna move
back this way
just in time for this to transform
then i'm gonna redo my energy
and i'm gonna put shield bot
they all do big damage so i'm gonna take
five damage no matter what but at least
i will have blocked the majority of it
i'm just gonna shield bot it and fishbot
you there and i'm gonna take
big damage
but that's okay
ew
oh
yeah yes good fish i got good fish yes
that's good it did
hell yeah you're gonna die
and then hopefully i can do enough
damage that i could actually win this
it's unlikely because i see that that
bomb bot is in a really inconvenient
place uh well um
whoa
that's a lot of things you can do
wow
okay
wow um
wish i could play both of these goddamn
interesting okay good fish you're gonna
go right
[Music]
there
and i think if i attack it first and
that way my grizzly can actually do the
damage
it's full damage that would be the best
way to do this
i think
you kill him bang
okay got him
well i will tell my future children of
this moment we will laugh together about
it one day
why did i do this to myself
oh thank you right you have sentry oh
there goes good fish
uh and there goes grizzly oh and then
here comes grizzly oh and there comes
grizzly i might be boned i might be
boned oh god damn it
oh no
oh no i can't play both these
okay i can take five damage but this
really isn't the best situation to be in
i can take the five damage i suppose
not much more than that
oh
no oh no
oh i forgot bulldown was going to move
[Music]
no
no i'll back and get back to the spot
without dying again oh damn it god damn
it
not so easy all the rogue bots in that
aria just respond i was i know i was
trying i was trying to be fancy with it
god damn it
if i just go up this way it should just
be right there oh well that's andy oh
well that was that wasn't so bad is
ah my bounty's gone i think it still
counts because i killed that dude so i
don't think he's gonna come back all
right grizz uh
i can't do anything
i need more energy bots that's what i
need
energy bot
but not what i'm gonna go for because as
soon as this comes in it's gonna die
from a meebot although i could use my
energy and then do energy bot again that
would give me three
useful
i could have done fishbot ah no i
couldn't have i just did energy but
that's why i was able to do that
take that
sentry's good
i like that
the
fish
oh i meant to oh you're fine
walk it off okay if you do that it's
gonna kill him i don't want to kill him
yet i do want the overkill
bad fish damn
okay
overkill time
yeah
oh whoops you right you're right sorry
okay
easy
thank you for the moolah
thank you
the guy who used to live here was
totally sloppy i don't mean he didn't
keep a clean cabin it was his plays he'd
make misplays left and right cared more
about lore and flavor you get it right
perfect strategy is that all that
matters isn't in card game
right okay yeah sure
sure buddy oh secret way
[Music]
oh
well i got the man the poor rabbits they
really get the short end of their stick
on this
arrangement
thank you for the mula
can i go back to the shop or is
everything going to respawn again i'll
just wait until i get back out it's not
like i need more cards two robo bugs i
have two row bucks i'll take that i
didn't even need to go back to the shop
perfect
god damn can you guys give me like
something like energy bots
shield is good i like shield
but does this mean what does that mean
recycle i'm not the trader or anything
but there's gonna be a little give and
take here you'll have to trade one of
your cards for one of these
okay
um
i don't really like the grizz it's not
very good sony is good because at least
sony can still attack all the time
okay what will you give me
i'll give you grizz i actually i like
grizz very little it's too expensive and
i can't do much with it
oh hello
oh animal time
all right lo
oh come on he can't even be there all
right fishbot you're up
what do you want okay
wolfham's oh
it's pretty good
i mean i do like the straight up just
damaged but but he does seem poisonous
this guy it's a venomous fish look at
those hicks in his mouth he's basically
a snake that works for me instant kill
anything i like it it's always useful
like tactically useful
not what i would have picked well you're
an idiot so
what does your opinion matter nothing
okay is this the boss
not yet i bet
sonja
sonjunt
well i'm not gonna be able to do
anything about it so i guess i just
gotta eat that so i won't even play my
empty vessel because i don't know where
i wanted to be
ow
sonja
all right well at least eat this hit
that's good
and then all right
man these guys are just chewing me up
let's go ahead and bomb this unless i
could do something else whiz bob what
could you do
nothing
amiibo you explode
no that's convenient
i was just talking about exploding
okay you would kill both of those things
but it would leave me vulnerable to
death
that's blown up
what are you gonna do
there she
goes kaboom
nice oh
wait no stop stop no oh
oh
[Music]
no god damn it
thank you for the money
all right
easy now just do this less stupidly
i just really don't have a lot of
defense for
slighty creatures
that's the unfortunate thing
do
[Music]
damn ow
you and your flight right over me god
damn you suck
okay
well none of you can fly over me right
now
but i need to do some damage or i'm
gonna die i know i can survive another
turn
there's energy bot
very helpful buddy energy but
there
shield bought there okay
should be good
oh yeah i forgot about the overkill
damage
oops
[Music]
all right we're good we're good lonely
whiz boy
liz wizbot lonely whiz boy and i think i
got a clear shot to do some big damage
with
the gunman
kill energy bot okay
and now we're good
go oh that's not nearly enough to kill
but it's enough to give me a head which
is what i really need
that's a lot though actually
oh it was just enough no overkill but
i'm okay with that i just needed that
done
hey
look at that
my items are replenished and those bots
back there permanently offline
what would you look at that
what's in here
oh god eerie this uber bot just sits
here in perfect darkness
is it's waiting for challengers maybe
it's letting its photos develop oh god
i wasn't ready for that the next boss is
pretty cool you all actually need to
think about your plays whole new
mechanic okay where are those files what
are you unpacking photographer.zip oh
the lens is my instrument
you as well are my instrument you will
aim and i will capture
oh
aha play me what
i wasn't ready for this i was actually
gonna
take a little breather go back to the
shop or something before all this
happened i don't know what's happening
play an empty vessel i guess
oh god hey this is my friend you blame
them
you will produce a photograph or you may
decide not to that is your choice
okay
i will how do i aim them i don't know
how to aim them
my friend will remember that photograph
my friend will allow you to use that
photograph to what end you will see oh
is it gonna like reset the board to that
to use when you will see
okay well i don't like this uh
whoa uh
wow that's um
those are just all gonna kill me
okay
uh-huh i see
good thing there's a shield okay the
shield's good because then the shield
means that
i don't know what
i don't know
i don't know why i'm taking these
pictures it's gonna tell me eventually
but probably way too late
okay so basically only shielded things
are gonna be able to survive here
[Music]
i think i can survive these three hits
or else i would just
i think i can survive these three but
i'm not 100 sure
okay very dangerous okay why am i taking
these pictures i do not know i need to
be able to survive more hits
which i think means i need empty vessels
so i'm if i put no they're gonna get
shot god damn it maybe i should have
used the bomb
bomb would have been good okay but i
think i'm gonna be okay
for now anyway
yeah you die but i got my energy that's
all that matters i'm gonna do three
and he's gonna take three
all right it's fine
okay
[Music]
okay it's fine surprisingly that's fine
oh
interesting
fascinating here's what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna smash this
put down the double gunner here this
will be good
that's gonna come kill it next turn but
it's fine
at least it'll give me a little ahead
that's okay that's okay because i got a
clear space on this one
oh i used it up once okay interesting
ah okay so now i know what the deal is
with this thing i wasn't 100 sure what
was going on but now i know what is
actually happening here
all right energy bot that doesn't do me
any good
shield is going to go
there because that's what that needs
empty vessel you're going to go
there because that can tank a hit
or two oh right the poison i'm an idiot
well energy bot you're up
god damn it
i could bolt hound
might be worth it
now let's try that
[Music]
okay
some progress
[Music]
ow there goes lonely wizbot
bye bot bud
okay but i could bring him back i would
lose out on shield bot hey let's bring
it back let's do that let's do that
thing
okay
a me bot that's less helpful
but maybe more helpful than i think
okay all right we're on the way we're on
the way
we're on the way
okay take a picture yeah okay now that i
know what this does i can actually use
it to my advantage
maybe let's just hold off because i have
the picture
okay
resume from the picture lonely whiz bus
just sticking around this whole time
good boss
yeah remind me of lushy fish good boss
okay sure whatever you say
what if i do this
i'm fish now cause i'll attack i'll win
i'm gonna win i'm not gonna win with a
lot of overkill but i'm gonna win unless
it's a two health it's a two health
thing i knew it you've done me a blow
you have you've dealt me a blow
recalibrating personality matrix
oh well that's exactly where all my
things are
uh
well this isn't exactly a picture i want
to take but whatever it's good enough
it'll do i guess
uh oh what if i blow up everything and
then go back to that other picture right
wouldn't that be a thing i
i don't want to break that tree i guess
it's just a matter of time so why waste
why
why rush it you know
all right
whatever
huh
nice oh
[Music]
all right um i actually don't want to
undo what i did
um
take this picture
and double gunners good where could you
do the most damage
i'm not gonna be picky
i think that does it i think that does
it yes that do it with some overkill
thank you
thank you kindly
hey i won why you so sour puss
oh
all right
hey look at that
i got some essence or something i don't
know
thank you
what is this oh
oh
remember your side deck
that useless thing with all the empty
vessels it's about to get less useless
oh thank you whoa
your pick will be installed on every
card
oh
well i mean the thorns
i think would be the way to go unless
i'm going to see more of those snake
bite things but the thorns the ability
to kill something that hits it is gold
i think anyway thorns
interesting i'm not sure that was right
but they all have sharp quills now great
good
excellent what is this about all right
so this one's run a bit long for me but
i was just having a lot of fun so i'm
gonna end this episode here thank you
everybody so much for watching look
forward to more inscription coming very
soon
we're really uncovering something here i
just don't know what it is we'll figure
that on the next episode thank you and
as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you